Tijuana Mexico on the border with the
United States and close to the Pacific
Ocean it's one of the busiest border
crossings in the world every day 50,000
cars and 25,000 pedestrians pass through
here in addition around 300 illegal
immigrants from various Latin American
countries cross the border daily
dreaming of a better life in the u.s.
most of the illegal migrants deported
back to Mexico end up here on the
rubbish strewn riverbed of the Rio
Tijuana Canal almost all have the same
wish get a little olive with you get it
a little bit I want to go back to the
other side says this man nothing else
but you have to be careful they don't
catch you when you cross but I got me
now next time there's fall I'm gone I'll
go back to my friends in San Diego I see
the canal lies next to the border fence
it leaves a lasting impression on
visitors to Tijuana around 2000 deported
people live in holes in the ground
or crude shelters no more welcome here
than they were across the border
Vicki Nia Sanchez lived happily in the
US for years until authorities
apprehended her she was sent back to a
country she hardly knew with no money
and no identity papers Sima pudiera
they threatened me with a five to 20
year prison sentence if I tried to cross
the border again she says what am I
supposed to do I really want to get
across but I can't I want to hold my
children again I miss them so much
especially at night Virginia has lived
on the canal for the last two years
drug addiction adds to her misery her
children live with her sister in San
Diego she has no contact with them
Roberto Marquez grew up in San Diego he
became a father but then he got into a
fight and killed a man he and his friend
guard Ito have lived here for the past
three years since Marquez was released
from jail he was deported without the
chance to bid his son farewell yours
I was 18 when I went to prison Marquez
says 17 wavey from 1979 to 2010 where
I'm not think they even are you in
platoon that's 31 years nothing that but
yes I did kill the man I see made only
this a little it's painful to say he
says but it was a better life for me
behind bars in the States
than it is here with this kind of
freedom
just 100 meters away there's another
Tijuana close proximity to the US means
jobs and industry young people are
looking to earn and spend money plenty
of them are successful bar owner Sergio
Gonzalez says the spectrum of nightlife
has developed enormous leap from simple
bars where workers go to high-end
gastronomy there's the art scene he says
and the architecture Tijuana is a young
City and it's growing rapidly in fact
the city's growing at a rate of two
hectares per month it's known for being
home to businesses that make cheap goods
by offering starvation wages but now
more high-tech products are being made
mostly for the American market the head
of the Industrial Association says that
four years ago drug violence over ran
the city today it's a different story
like in the PMMA quarter supporting you
guys and deewana people here have better
opportunities than in other cities he
says that's why so many people come to
Tijuana it's a challenge for the city
the development of infrastructure and
social services can't keep pace yes what
the million dramatic one now so despite
all the growth month there have been
some setbacks honester several years the
glistening charities and the Catholic
Church have stepped in every morning
father Ernesto n unders offers breakfast
to more than a thousand deported illegal
migrants without his help some of the
poorest people around the canal would
starve the most fundamental is that
little money meant a healthy breakfast
is important he says so that people
don't have to steal and they stay
healthy with a little care they can get
back on their feet again but most don't
want to make lives for themselves in
Tijuana the people who eat here aren't
interested in the nightlife or working
in the factories
I'm from El Salvador says this man but
they deported me to Mexico
the Americans just think well he's
Latino
they don't care which country you're
from this man says the police took away
his papers so he's stuck here without
them he says he can't go anywhere
I only met one person who wants to stay
Brunell Alvarez what a chemical or not
Bruno is a great example says father
Hernandez he too lived in a hole in the
ground at the canal but he didn't give
up and he kept looking for a chance to
get out he often had breakfast here so I
knew him and I knew he would be great
for this project now he works and sleeps
here
Bruno takes us back to the canal to show
us how hard it is for the people who end
up here and why so few make it across
the border again what what etham water
it's because of this fence says Bruno
and they put ladders up and climb over
but at the top they have to jump most of
them injure themselves they break their
legs came and many died on the other
side as they try to cross the desert
bear there's my turn but the migrants
aren't welcomed in Tijuana either the
stark poverty he shows us his proof of
that
he came here after the American police
took him from his house and deported him
he was taken away from his wife his two
daughters and his two grandchildren and
found himself in Mexico living in a hole
in the ground
I care if they're on boom this is the
hole where I used to live he says
together with around 12 to 15 others as
though what well I gather all other
whenever the police came they would
destroy what little we still had those
who live on the canal hate the police
they say the city just wants to get rid
of them the Chief of Police points out
that there's now a service in place to
help them leave quanto as Retiro
Dilophosaurus IE when the plan is that
we ask the people to go back to their
home countries he says after all they
all have relatives in other countries we
even pay for their travel Rob your yaki
en cuanto inland the state helps where
it can come and we're only doing it in
their interest
Khandala dependent a catalan bluebird
anita todo que todos que tienen tibetan
solution r lo la primera ax young Victor
Clark from the binational Center for
Human Rights says the authorities have
sent in police with heavy machinery to
destroy the homeless people's shelters
in Canal and when they took some of the
residents away and locked them up he
says only to let them go again a few
hours later to raise awareness of police
brutality some residents from the canals
have set up a protest camp with the help
of human rights organizations they're
demonstrating against unjust arrests
evictions and the fact that police
consistently destroy their homes without
providing an alternative Westgate
sacramentum which is equals this is con
nosotros in Canada this man says that
the canal residents must deal with huge
in Justices they take our money he says
they beat us and kick us out anyone who
makes some money or receive some from
his family often loses it to the police
sociologists have begun to pay attention
to the situation
louder Velasco documents the stories of
those who've been deported
Blandon in protest this is a protest
against the apathy of the authorities
she says they haven't even managed to
give these people a decent place to
sleep
the city is leaving people who've been
deported out in the cold there are no
social services here today the
sociologist wants to visit the canal
residents to collect data but she's
received a telephone threat the callers
said that if she brought journalists to
the area something bad would happen to
her but she isn't convinced you think
all this bingo bingo glue that I doubt
that call came from the canal residence
she says I've been doing this work for a
long time I've met with them alone and
as part of a group they trust me no one
has ever been aggressive towards me me
also say vok me a grave algún that's why
I can't believe that people from the
canal would threaten to kill me if I
came to see them
around 2000 people live on the canal
they're not wanted here
they don't want to be here but they
can't leave they find themselves on the
wrong side of the border close and yet
impossibly far from their American dream
the border crossing has become more and
more dangerous for many trying to get to
the US can prove deadly and yet those
who've decided to stay in Mexico remain
the exception rather than the rule it's
for more for Mikey cuando you i've
noticed that over there i was nobody
says bruno alvarez now I finally have
proper papers again and suddenly I feel
like I'm someone again a Mexican what
was that make it kind of then well one
guy vivid all my life isn't here in
Mexico says Roberto Marquez I still have
a life in the United States that's why I
can never make a life here
you